Olá no vídeo de hoje eu decidi inventar
a nova sopa do McDonald's mais
propriamente a sopa de Big Mac eu não
sei ao certo como fazer isto ainda mas
eu vou tentar juntar o Big Mac com água
triturar aquilo tudo juntar a batata
juntar nega que talvez juntar a
coca-cola na Sopa e vamos ver como vai
ficar será que vai ficar bom pessoal
assistir um vídeo falar pelos pessoal
daqui fala mandar aqui sejam muito bem
vindos a mais um vídeo e eu gosto fracos
aqui com o verão ver pelo título hoje
vamos tentar inventar uma sopa de
Beakman é hora de jantar eu estava aqui
com fome e eu pensei porque não comer
uma sopinha algo saudável uma sopa de
batata de próculo assim tão cenoura sei
lá tomar sopa como todos nós conhecemos
mais Dark frame queria algo mais queria
algo mais inusitado e eu pensei porque
não pegarem alguma comida que já estamos
habituados uma comida deliciosa
obviamente Big Mac e tornou-a em sopa
porque submetrico sólido é bom hein sopa
também poderá ser então hoje vamos fazer
essa sopa de Big Mac para e eu não sei
sério eu não faço ideia se vai ficar bom
senão vai ficar comente já embaixo só
que vocês acham se acham que vai ficar
nojento comenta aí está sempre vai ficar
bom comentem também enfim vamos lá
preparar a nossa sopa
Eu também quero comer a minha sopa e eu
sei que é
hoje
vai ser só uma Big Mac não vai não vai
ser do teu é
Oi Luzia Como é que é você se a sopa mas
isso sopa saudável saudável hahaha faz
malucas
pela fruta que fica bom né
de sopa com hambúrguer que vai sentir
tudo no mesmo sítio tipo um olho vamos
ficar não base vai ficar tudo pessoal
ela não conhece os meus dotes culinários
Ok eu tenho certeza que vai ficar vó ela
está a duvidar de mim é um vão e quando
eu acabar de fazer a sopa eu não te vou
dar nem uma colherada nenhuma nenhuma
vai ser só olha já agora já estás aqui
tu vai começar a filmar torta mas eu não
é
E aí
ah
é verdade não tem como tu perguntar de
mim
não é mesmo na cabeça pa Olha que é que
eu quero ver como é que você não vai dar
sopa não eu acho que até atuar pelo Tom
aa
[Música]
Oi e a pessoal não ficar um papel
higiênico é melhor agora sim posso comer
uma sopa tigela Ok então eu pensei que
eu ia comer a sopa aqui no prato eu tô
com fome não sou eu não sou eu quando
tem que fazer barulho
[Música]
um
pauzinho Eu tô maluco
E aí
O que são só esse vídeo eu tento
se alguém vai
Ah não você não é que nós temos aqui
para nossa sopa obviamente o nosso Big
Mac vamos ver se vê em condições olha
para ele que lindo
meu este aqui tá perfeito McDonald's tá
Ah mas calma que ainda tem mais
também qualquer boa sopa Leva Nós temos
aqui é melhor batata todas não
e
vai ficar incrível pessoal acompanha até
o fim e topping
bem
simples Big Mac batata vamos ver o que é
que vai dar ainda posso ser um cara que
chato mas acho que é um pouco exagerado
olha
E aí
E aí já fica estranho
mas não
o meu e vamos ao assunto eu precisava
era de água então eu vou ficar só
preciso juntos aqui um pouquinho de água
só porque eles vão ter consoante a minha
receita ou amanhã Ou pelo menos 300
mililitros acho que é suficiente que
estás a inventado
na frente o cozinheiro
dá mais notícia é que o dinheiro agora
daqui nossa arma do crime é isto vai
destruir o Big Mac Então acho que isso é
má
E aí
[Música]
e não vai ficar boa eu juro para ficar
confia em x com água e casado a nossa
E aí vocês vão fazer essa receita em
casa vamos explicar
bom
então vem com o Big Mac e eu não sei se
devo isso aí com causar tudo né porque
ele não cabe neste Celeste O quê um copo
de medição
nós vamos partir ao meio e
E aí
e finança
o primeiro ingrediente be como é que ele
tem um
tu quer o gênero
a atenção não se desperdice a comigo ok
é uma fazer tudo o hotel faço tudo
quanto + alface + todas
em fibras OK segunda passo triturar já
um hambúrguer depois voltamos as batatas
Ok vamos ver como é que é
o
rosto
afundado primeiro Nossa Hambúrguer 1
eu já faço com aquele aspecto saboroso
tá
já está tudo parece que vamos triturar
E aí
é
incrível tipo pode ser um hambúrguer em
13 segundos um
E aí
a
espera pão bem mas tão bem que era
incrivelmente feito já era chato hoje
[Música]
o sol
ingredientes batata
batata volta mas a triturar o
E aí
o
OK agora já parece ser mais uma sopa
eu tava muito líquido
e é por isso que as mães juntam sempre
abata
é
visualmente isso não é muito à frente né
olha aí ó
é isso parece papa de aveia com limitada
e
vamos fingir que está tudo bem excitado
ingrediente nega como é que Donalds eu
vou juntar dois naqueles as pernas e os
outros quatro também como tá o fim da
nossa sopa porque vai te corre tudo mal
ainda temos 46 só quem aprende nada é só
para vir aqui com o molho para Nega
triturar net não
[Música]
E aí
O que é que fala vou colocar um pouco
mais de água aqui porque isso agora tá
aparecendo um purê e não é uma sopa mas
precisa um pouquinho mais de água e fica
lá no ponto ok
E aí
e agora é
E
tu vai
eu não ainda faço ingrediente especial a
nossa amiga e conhecida coca-cola
a completamente cheia um pouquinho de
Coca Cola assim é suficiente ao quer
pessoal só para dar aquele toque doce 31
perfeição
a refeição acaba com a fome no mundo
entende esta pessoa é a sensação do
momento Dark frame inventou a sopa
Olha lá alguém vir aqui jantar e por ser
vida não
calma vamos ver um sabor primeiro a
mesma aquele molho do Big Mac sabe agora
pessoal vamos colocar Então a nossa sopa
da taça três vezes não vai
e olha aí tá bem espessa Mas é mesmo
assim pessoal de virar a batata
perguntava que eu tenho que juntar aqui
e isso vai ficar assim com esta
consistência estranha Ok eu acho que
assim acesso sempre né acho que a
aguardavam lá
e
eu gosta ele gosta que ele deu uma
lambidinha é porque gosta
tudo é como eu e agora para finalizar
pessoal vamos colocar o nosso topping de
negras Olha isso sopa dormir
fato bom
e essa pessoal é nossa sopa de Big Mac
e já cheira a big mac Pessoal este é o
momento vamos fazer a nossa prova da
nossa só para dizer como é E ai ai estou
comendo a consistência está um bocadinho
duvidosa mas eu acho que o cozinheiro
está que sempre vai surpreender
e a consistência está ótima
eu não sei então pelo
deve ter pulado o que eu uso aqui para
dentro três dois um
bom
[Música]
então
sabe muita carne né
o
embate
é horrível eu
sabia ela
diz aprovadíssimo é assim em sabor o que
eu acho que falta apenas aqui nesta sopa
é o sala porque como nós não estamos
água obviamente para tantas de sal mas
tem sabor até faça o pior é mesmo a
textura a consistência
é uma coisa muito estranha porque sabe
como é que mas é um por é é muito
estranho
que passa em sabor pó sem sabor só
passam junto falta são os dois Vamos
experimentar aqui o nosso canal e
E aí
e onde é que até bom então vai na i
e
não é que falta saldos no sol
estava aprovado se tivesse Saulo eu juro
um
comida né
olha que
E aí
o
ok pessoal veredito final
não façam essa sopa em casa esta super
horrível A não ser que coloca muito sal
eu acho que ela fica boa mas para o
sucesso Ok eu estava super curioso para
saber de como é que fica uma sopa de Big
Mac parte Neste vídeo contas os amigos
em lá pelo WhatsApp não digo nada só
mandei o link é uma lata uma
E aí
[Música]
e não acaba
e não tá bom eu não
tenho como ficar muito bom mas eu não
tenho fome
[Música]
o que é só Salvo é nojento
é cada vez
menos mil pior coisa o
e agora ela exagerou pessoal que é que
chefe é bom agora ela e desejou Mas
enfim Só espero que tenham gostado aqui
deste vídeo Espero que tenha gostado
aqui desta experiência já sabem se
quiserem ver mais sopas com outras
comidas deste gênero tipo com Burger
King ou uma sopa de pizza o que for
comenta embaixo Pessoal espero que
tenham gostado fazer parar de dizer se
não partilharem este vídeo vai se
aparecer uma sopa destas você também vai
fazer isso para jantar eu acho que não
acho que todas as mães têm sanidade
mental suficiente para não fazer a sopa
Pois é isso Pessoal espero que tenham
gostado fiquei até agora o teu irmão e